an hour outside of Santiago in the San
Bernardo region Chileans have hit on the
newest superfood craze put down that
acai goji mangosteen kombucha and say
hello to Mackay berry Maqui has been
around for centuries it's a super berry
the native people of the mapuche tribes
have known this for centuries this is my
friend Boris Irma's he's the owner of
South ham freeze-dry where you guessed
it they freeze dry and packaged tasty
fruits and vegetables including the Maki
berry when the superfood searchers and
the scientists discovered the Maggie
what were the properties that they
discovered compared to other super foods
they realized that Maki has a very very
high antioxidant count which is just you
know really off the charts to see how
the Maki makes its way from the tree to
an overpriced cleanse Boris took me on a
tour of the factory so about to go into
the actual food part and we need to suit
up after transforming into two very hip
lunch ladies it was time to go inside
we're looking good and we're set man
okay let's go do this wait okay
this is where the process starts
we free said in a previous facility it's
brought here so we need to raise the
temperature of it wash it take out
sorter or the leaves the twigs
everything after the berries warm-up
they need to get cold again so they're
wheeled into a giant freezer after a few
hours
they're then wheeled into what's called
the freeze tunnel where they stay for
about 24 hours
as the tunnel sucks away all of their
moisture you basically create on a very
large scale a high vacuum the water
crystal in the food goes from solid into
gas state without going through the
liquid see preserving the nutritional
value of the food the boys didn't invent
this process far from it you obviously
have all this modern equipment but you
were saying in South America as some of
these techniques actually go back
hundreds of years it is said that the
ink has discovered a way to free try the
fruit given the high altitude in the
mountains that would have a lighted
pressure because of the atmosphere which
is what basically we do with the tunnels
and you have extreme changes of
temperature and then back in the 50s
NASA refined the process to create what
is known today as Austrian food which is
using all sorts of things
finally it was time for the most
important step the taste test we have
here Maki very blueberry pineapple and
banana powder to prepare smooth in your
honor you see how the purple over bumps
everything
so let's give it a try okay church is
salute it's the light I am look at our
lips it looks like lipstick that's a
nice color on you I saw the value and
freeze-drying the food gives it is fun
it's crunchy it's different too much
your ID it doesn't look like you consume
a lot of water when you could just flex
up the off the tree we try to be
efficient with it
we're basically what you're taking out
is the water that the the produce itself
has we recycle that water heating the
tunnels with warm water we've tried to
make it efficient with the micro
turbines so we try to balance it all and
keep our carbon path alone
Boris has already started selling the
Maki powder around the world for use in
smoothies and supplements may we all
have purple lips and live forever
[Music]
you
[Music]